King welcome to camp et thank you would
you feel like you're at summer camp yeah
I'm so high Oh miss summer camp it's
moving pieces oh you missed some again
yeah really yeah I never went to summer
camp myself really know at all so I
imagine this is what it's like like ring
pops coloring books yeah nothing like
sloppy joes we don't have sloppy joes
but we do have some more and I promise
you we made these chairs them dude mmm
yes I very good mm-hmm did you like knit
your first love that cam I'm a hassle no
no no people I can't wear a ratchet we
have fun though about other guy fell in
love with anybody like ah know how many
that comes has a big for this is my
fourth I think okay yeah so what is the
biggest difference for you since that
first time the first time it was just
chaos there was like a new organization
i think there's actually a video that
somebody was covering of us being like
dragged out in the courtyard with
security and now they have like cars
escorting us we go in like these
underground tunnels it's just it's very
extra it's very extra but very what kind
of necessary right there is necessary
it's kind of weird though because like
you come to meet everyone and be a part
of everything and now we're kinda
isolated I don't know how I feel about
it people around the world are coming
here to like physically well yeah for
VidCon which is crazy I had somebody my
line from London I was like okay alright
alright cool but they're going
international now good call yes that's
cool thanks for coming back to hang out
you we need to see you again yeah so
good to see we come back next summer
yeah you owe me you can be apt counselor
next year you got have you yes hi buddy
thank you fun this weekend see uniting
course more to go oh God thank you
mm-hmm